Así es fracturas por un lado del lado
republicano los más conservadores en el
partido republicano no están contentos
con que solo se haya acordado aumentar
el gasto en defensa un tres coma tres
por ciento el próximo año y tampoco
están contentos porque querían más
recortes en los gastos esta precisamente
fue la condición que ponían los
republicanos para aprobar este proyecto
para levantar el techo de la deuda que
separara el gasto público hubieran
recortes de parte de el gobierno en
programas sociales los demócratas por
otro lado Pues están Precisamente en
desacuerdo y no muy contentos con el
hecho de que se hayan congelado los
gastos en programas sociales de aquí al
2025 sobre todo en cuanto a subsidios de
alimentación a las personas de escasos
recursos en Estados Unidos
y además argumentan que dado que se
congela estos esta financiación a
programas sociales en Estados Unidos la
inflación va a terminar haciendo que en
términos reales haya una reducción en
los gastos a programas sociales en
Estados Unidos teniendo en cuenta que la
inflación supera el 5% acá es decir los
próximos dos años va a haber un recorte
real en esta inversión social en Estados
Unidos y a eso no le apuntaron los
demócratas inicialmente sin embargo los
moderados aprobaron en la cámara de
representantes este proyecto y se espera
que también sea el caso en el senado
Cristóbal como lo decía a pesar de las
divisiones finalmente se aprobó en la
cámara de representantes y como usted
nos acaba de mencionar ahora Pasa este
texto al senado que se sabe de lo que va
a suceder en esta cámara y cuándo qué
tiempos habría en esta votación
[Aplausos]
es el líder de La minoría republicana en
la cámara alta es decir en el senado
dijo incluso que la votación se podría
dar hoy mismo lo que están tratando de
hacer
que es el líder demócrata en el senado
de hecho es el líder del senado teniendo
en cuenta que tiene la mayoría del
partido demócrata en la cámara alta Pues
están tratando de negociar con
algunos senadores que han dicho que van
a tratar de hacer enmiendas a este
proyecto de ley que fue aprobado en la
cámara de representante anoche y
entonces lo que quieren Precisamente es
que estas enmiendas no demoren el
proceso teniendo en cuenta que no hay
tiempo para poder gastar en debates de
pequeñas enmiendas en este proyecto
entonces de hecho hoy en la plenaria del
senado dijo que en las sesiones van a
continuar abiertas hasta que se haga la
votación y pues hay esperanzas de que
sea hoy mismo a más tardar mañana
viernes que haya ya el voto definitivo
lo que dicen analistas legislativos acá
en Washington es que el paso por el
senado es muy positivo teniendo en
cuenta que ya los dos partidos han
expresado su apoyo públicamente a este
proyecto de ley es decir lo único que
falta es tratar de animar esas asperezas
en las enmiendas que quieren hacer
algunos senadores para que se vote se
vote a favor y el proyecto de ley vaya a
la mesa del presidente